Minecraft's month how is your minecraft
month tell me what are you doing for
minecraft mod 'minecraft a year question
mark welcome back to LA it's time for
Minecraft me I don't make mine kripp
Sears said no one
it started off completely ironic and now
it's 100% on ironic I'm a minecraft
channel I don't care
do you know how much I enjoy just
playing games again it feels like I get
a second chance of being a being a kid
again it's wonderful let's get into the
memes meanwhile in an alternate universe
Katdare whoever did the hey stop hello
how my skin looks like a sheep it's so
awful ah please I'm sorry I'm sorry what
their sheep I didn't understand I just
didn't understand of course we also have
to address the elephant in the room
uragan rest in peace legends never die
Jurgen too has passed away
sorry spoilers but I think it's a good
time as any to have something to laugh
about
some memes to appreciate
did the lysis change or am I crazy your
again juergen second who's a good boy
who's a good boy who's a good boy oh
yeah who did this meme Dec Ning doctor
what amazing I love he woke up further
than I rather get it hey it's been a
surprisingly good boy lately you know
Edgar listens to my videos as well
whenever I do the intro he always sits
down because he knows I'm about to
record and whenever I do an outro even
though I don't have an outro he can
still tell and he gets excited what if
he knows about Sven oh my god guys don't
tell Edgar but spend okay another
amazing fan art by Nate Eric's got it
well okay well he did it I need to get
another iron golem oh my gosh I said it
wrong it's stone golem amazing Sven
loyalty three blasts protection for
feather for him for echo infinity Jurgen
pairs of banishing van after surviving
the tenth creeper explosion steak steak
will bring spend through I cannot deal
with any more you may take my horse you
may take my water sheep but my minecraft
dog will live forever yes I just ignore
water cow I don't care about water cow
no one cares about water count IKEA was
so popular in PewDiePie's minecraft a
series that they made one in real life
what why does it look fake though I feel
like maybe you guys can relate to this
but once you play enough minecraft you
look at certain structures and you're
like that would look good in Minecraft I
bet I could build that in Minecraft no I
don't have problem when you invite her
over to play minecraft but she starts
reaching for your diamond leg games
why are you near my feet can we just
appreciate the lines on the headset and
the chair could be what brought this has
to be experimentation how the Frick did
I do that
Oh No what you never played to pursue
Bellator I just realized I can
technically review the memes like this
and you will still see it so why not
there's a way Felix can bring a panda
home don't let this Diane Lewis what
okay no way that will what what with
femto why is he carrying baby
why is your getting grey with this thing
Jurgen can never target can never fit in
boat delete this right now this is fake
this is how you know it's fake
dinnerbone is near minus 200 oh I forgot
about that sad moment when Dinnerbone is
technically more safe at the bottom of
the ocean
it's not called being lost it's called
tactical placement Felix she's probably
thinking about the wedding
marzia she makes a church for watashi o
yeah cuz I I told you guys that it was
my dad's idea with the water sheep
Church which was a damn good idea
because so far everything just it's
gotten worse you know I'm starting to
think that water sheep isn't such a good
person after all I don't know is it just
me or for tonight youtubers when
fortnight is losing popularity you know
what I'm something of a Minecraft
youtuber myself I mean I can't really
fault it I mean I guess I played it for
the mean but I haven't paid attention to
what anyone's doing and it's so goddamn
liberating Alayna t through a cat okay
great I don't care I just want to plain
buy boots in 2015 oh no it's really cool
to have an audience that enjoys what I
enjoy and I don't have to be playing
minecraft every day or some F in 2019
it's another beautiful day in Minecraft
this is interesting because how do I
explain this because this ties into why
I never played Minecraft because
minecraft became so explosively popular
right
and and and everyone would just play it
and it felt like people were playing it
just because it was popular and not
because they were actually doing it and
people literally base their entire
channel around Minecraft
I mean I'd literally done the same so
but it it's different because for a lot
of these channels that would be it you
know they play minecraft and they can't
move on to something else what I always
enjoy with YouTube was that I could do
different things and I still have an
audience doing different things
especially back in 2015 like there's so
many big minecraft channels then that
don't exist today because their work
didn't translate into other stuff and
eventually people get bored of it it's
not to rip into them but it's also one
of the reasons where I was like well I
don't want to become like that it seems
awful but then again Here I am you know
if minecraft gets boring I can just move
on to other things it will never happen
spend purposely hurting himself to get a
free steak steaks good meme how spent
has not died hair hair hair hair hair
watching peopIe let's play Burke huh
Sven come with me Sven this is a portal
to go back be more careful this side
death is watching my minecraft letsplay
guys this is huge def is sponsoring this
let's play that's epic remember him this
is him haha oh my god the camera angle
as well and then attend me I am gonna
kidnap more people I know how to do it
now
the best fighting strategy I've seen in
a while Wow oh it's Homer Simpson meme I
got it see I got the meme I still I'm
still fresh down with the memes okay
just cuz I play Minecraft doesn't know
yeah it took me a bit long in it I bet
it went down this way hey Marcia I'm
gonna do a live stream with Jack Black
mine's yet oh really he was flat for his
crush Felix
say snack right now
I mean yeah 100% poor both cow brooch
I can explain my church isn't big enough
you got a church I only got a grape
you guys are getting great good me did
me you guys always act like you're
better than me I guess you could put
fortnight reading in the corner or
something I don't know Sven - nothing
PewDiePie incredible job or scientists
okay I made your house a more epic and
more Swedish see this is what I was
talking about yes okay that dress is a
guy big cool it's a baby the thing is
like yeah this is dope as freak and I
really appreciate it but at the same
time it's like anytime I update my house
it's not gonna look as good as this and
it'll just be a disappoint you can
increase the size of Tree of Life
wait there is just skin Tree of Life you
can't your skin Tree of Life all right
no problem bro I'll just I'll just build
this in a second it's whatever purified
so I made a few changes to the house
between videos the house before but us
release the footage we need to see the
creation of the Swedish meatball he
definitely made it himself
parts aren't even thanks guys you
literally just build it ground up it's
so easy that's how all meatballs are
made from the earth that's where they
get their wisdom and sexiness for things
are infinite the universe numbers winrar
30-day trial
Sven's health did you know you can look
at this tail and the angle of the tail
means his life what what is that an
enderchest gucci armor no way
the pewdiepie pack with the weimar yeah
mom can we have Bob rush no there is Bob
Ross at home
Oh
oh my god that is perfect I feel like
I've seen this before but that is the
most perfect lineup thing I've ever seen
there's a rare IKEA fish well I need it
now
give it to me give it to me Felix
inventory cévennes
inventory pd pie with Jack Black
Peter pie with James Charles pity pie
with Ken who died recording alone
yeah me and Ken is like a married old
couple everyone keeps saying it
I built a Jurgen out of Legos what
that's awesome I want a Jurgen out of
Legos I only post late at night in the
US because Europeans are nicer and
that's a fact
are we I didn't know okay pewds missed a
hidden chest in the jungle temple helped
him see I found it
thank you I went back to get all the
cobblestone and stuff like that maybe I
should stop playing without the camera
it won't be interesting I'm just like I
need to get the cobblestone that's all I
do and I say nothing there's no point
time traveler who are you watching me
PvP time traveler oh you mean biggest
for a night channel me say psych right
now on vacation with my cousin
we found IKEA burn what I can't part so
popular that may hit him into real life
what that's crazy
where do you go from being the biggest
reaction youtuber to be the biggest
biker patient I have fear of pewdiepies
outro therapist what don't worry guys
there won't be the pewdiepie out tree in
this video because I'm editing today's
video and because I'm too lazy to
download it and put it inside the edit
so don't worry there won't be any outro
now that Pierce is true minecraft there
he will be extremely uncomfortable
looking at these
I guess I'm not there yet like that
looks awesome what you can do that
beauty pie logic can anyone understand
it Peter pie this game makes zero sense
older PewDiePie bamboo Frick yeah I can
make shampoo well they try me dummy
anything is possible if it rhymes
you dummy dumb Felix last surviving
horse dinner bone is still at the bottom
of the ocean so he means to rescue him
oh well I already recorded the next
episode and it's not what I'm doing okay
I'll stop playing for a couple days just
super cat caught up okay I kind of got a
little head of myself but I don't want
to stop wait there's another ikea bird
there's an ikea bird that looks like
that can I die him but if I put dye on
him like the Sheep can I tie him how do
I find that IKEA bird villager spends
entire life mastering crack to become
lesser worker and provide for family
feud you're our new DJ's I keep
struggling to find a DJ how many people
have we had as a DJ at this point
I wish then could ride on Jurgen that
would be so cute Mojang right yeah right
I mean it's not a bad idea
petition for pigs to sell Schumer that
accident looks pretty good
damn Felix after killing ender dragon
ender dragon was like a father to me
okay you will never understand nine
girls after every nine craft video okay
okay more manga please haha we've come a
long way fam how do I make it boom I I
feel like my elevator everyone seems so
impressed by it like if you knew how it
works you would not behave like this it
just looks it looks complicated this cuz
of all the wiring me what a random guy
you never
later template me do you understand me
how how do you know the forbidden
language nobody Jack Black in
PewDiePie's house not funny
didn't laugh oh go on here we go
pity pie builds a grave from gold for
his favorite [ __ ] all solidified
builds a grave from emerald blocks a
huge meatball with an elevator I'm glad
you pointed that out and a beautiful
church for a sheep he hated you'll never
understand this you'll never understand
with me in water sheep had Minecraft
Monday's are better than fortnight
Fridays and that's a fact
Thank You metric very cool Peter by
doing there's 8,000 - content creators
mental health charity in honor of
etiquette that's sweet
yes I saw this and it was super helpful
Thank You Maxime zero I'm learning a lot
of our edge stones this next one really
really helped me that the block power
one yet no this one I didn't know they
could send a signal through a block that
was really useful actually because then
you can power it from the sides super
epic having an iron golem that is not
yours could be dangerous bids if you
accidentally hit him Sven could try and
attack it and would kill when you think
it's when we lose against stone man get
out of here plus they keep despawning
because I keep forgetting to gave them a
name tag what's worse than heartbreak
falling into lava and losing your
diamond can confirm what IKEA Tower was
became so popular that it became a thing
in real life what people finding
purifies minecraft seed is just making
it worse for pews as he said he wanted
to give it after he had fought the ender
dragon so people wouldn't ruin the
experience for him since the cities are
now please don't ruin it for pills don't
worry about it okay I said in the last
video that I didn't want the minecraft
seed it sounds so weird
using my seed but apparently some very
nifty people figured out what my
minecraft seed is just by pinpointing
locations in my map which is pretty
awesome it's pretty impressive
but ironically at the very same time I
send my video I that I don't want to
keep my seed because I don't want people
to spoil but no one's pulled so far so I
think it's totally fine
basically this means you all can
experience meetings juergen and spend
for the first time yourself when Felix
grandkids ask him if he knows who this
PewDiePie guy from their history
textbook is well of course I know him
he's me my gosh I really do look like
everyone that is terrifying Jurgen died
after exiting from the nether a place
full of magma box
Sven nearly died when Pierce boat was
pulled down by magma Bluffs water sheep
got crushed by magma blocks there's too
many patterns here and I don't like it
are we gonna talk about how both Jurgen
one and me Jurgen two suffocated F in
the chat box who is waiting for me
defied to do something wrong for a month
35 who just wants to play my crack
another reason why I love minecraft
started out as an Ikea power in my
creative world turned into a tribute to
the entire series up to height limit
damn well the [ __ ] says they got
diamonds that is epic whoa that's so
cool with a wavy flag what is that is
that water sheep oh my gosh
100 million that is sick dude I was
actually really do let's look at the
whole thing
when Felix forgot about saving
Dinnerbone two episodes in a row sad
Dinnerbone noises sorry didn't there
bone you're gonna have to hang out for
at least then one more okay Felix
actually regrets it here's a message
from what the Sheep okay
I think someone's knocking nah I'm gay
gamer hundred alright gamers thanks for
smashing like and watching another video
I really appreciate it
check out merch if you want Memoriam for
Jurgen to F's in the chats and I see you
guys tomorrow what you never played oh
but Emma later you know it's fun right
well I'll cut you a deal test out the
game and then you can tell me you like
it or not and it's free and that's a
great price I don't know I have no
memory clears me